Dead Rising 4 won't be in our hands till
December but we already know about the
games DLC plans I'm Tony and this game
spot News Update comes with a few extras
Microsoft has announced the content for
Dead Rising for season pass including an
18-hole mini golf course it's called
super ultra Dead Rising for mini golf
and you can play online with up to four
people and you'll use guns instead of
golf clubs the season pass also includes
the stocking stuffer holiday pack which
will grant you some holiday themed
costumes and vehicles and weapons
finally you'll get an expansion called
Frank rising in which protagonist Frank
West must find a cure after he gets
infected by a zombie
Debrecen forest season pass will cost
you 25 bucks but it's also included with
the game's $80 deluxe edition Dead
Rising 4 launches on Xbox one and PC on
December 6th the season pass is
available on both platforms but it's
unknown whether the extra content will
be available separately keep an eye on
gamespot for more coverage as we get
closer to launch and for all the biggest
Dead Rising news you're already in the
right place